what's up everybody welcome back to the
live Raspberry Pi video look here we
have the Raspberry Pi in question
wow I just hit my knee on this table I'm
sorry table anyway this is our Raspberry
Pi I just put the case on it I really
like the case highly recommend it it's
like perfectly like you kind of expected
it's clearly like probably machine-cut
and math oh but uh actually fits really
well so I'm really happy with anyway
enough about the case we've got our SD
card or mouse train over here really
necessary that you have like 19 map mice
I wonder if it's mice or Mouse's anyway
continue when i'm prime mice but I've
heard people say Mouse's today but once
you have your SD card this is my SD card
as you can see I actually did hook it
with that scotch tape on it because it
was being bigger so the SD card on your
master prize actually may go right in
here kind of the underside you can see
where the clips bar and I think was
holding like wherever here anyway you
can see we're like the only know what
those are even called I don't know bars
you can see where the ought to match up
with this so anyway you'll just slip
this your SD card in there in there and
it's in there now the next thing if you
have a monitor you can either plug into
your RTA or what the heck is the HDMI
cable right there I just don't happen to
have this lovely HDMI cable that's where
I'm gonna stick it so she said and my
cables in there next thing if you want
to have internet right now we don't
absolutely need it but if you want you
can pull your Ethernet cable in there
there's a couple things that we want to
have is a mouse for
using mice like things so stick the
mouse in there you should have oh man
this mouse is like really stiff hold on
to me hold it one thing you would do
kind of want to be careful about like
this at least mine is the the USB is
like really stiff especially with this
and you can see it's just you know it
just mounted upwards so if you're
sticking something especially in the top
slot you could be kind of creating
leverage enough that break it's a just
over time you wouldn't want to break
that down so you know you might want to
help when you push that ends this kind
of delicate machinery here at now next
thing we want is a keyboard which I just
so happened to have a keyboard back from
like I don't know 1998 or something
but actually you know back in 1998 when
they made computer equipment it lasted
you know as opposed to nowadays guys
anyway this this keyboard is still
kicking it so we're gonna be using it so
you just plug that in and then finally I
think we've got everything we want
plugged in besides power now just keep
in mind when you do plug in power it's
going to power up you will rest very PI
so you kind of want to make that the
last thing that you do otherwise you're
gonna be scrambling to catch up with
options so now power let's talk about
power real quick let me find mine
well you know what there's like a huge
mess of wires back here and I can't yes
so anyway the power supply anyway is
gonna be basically any regular mini USB
or micro USB charger like you would have
for your cell phone nothing you want to
pay attention to is if it's just
straight up the USB cable don't plug it
straight into your computer because the
computer can vary a lot as far as what
it's pushing and so what you want to use
is something that plugs into a plug and
you you want at least well everything
has to be 5 volts and then you want at
least 700 milliamps but if you push in
like all this stuff like we've got a
wireless mouse keyboard HDMI cable here
now you're kind of pushing it so you
might want to have more like
thousand millions at least so but once
you finally go lay completely headless
seven hundred is fine but if you are
gonna start well never mind anyway um so
that's that that's what we're gonna do
we're shut this thing up and let's plug
in the power so the power supply again
it goes kind of run out of wires here
here we go it's just right in there so
you'll plug in the power once you plug
it in and everything is on you'll see
there's some lights going so you'll know
that you've at least started some sort
of thing it's Tron this screen here if
we arrive at anything I am just
reinstalling this so who knows I'm gonna
fried the entire pie but I doubt it